I mentioned that polynomials was one of
our weak points okay so we've got some
stuff to review over the next few weeks
let's have a look at this question
showed that given this P of Z polynomial
show that I W and 1 on W are also Druce
okay so most people got right I'm
supposed to use the factor theorem here
so most people said okay I'll substitute
in iw I'll give that a go and when you
can see you're either than eight you're
out of the four we know that those
simplify out so that was fine but when
we got to this substituting in the
reciprocal of W right the most common
error was the students saw this thing
and they said Oh gross fractions
I don't want fractions the only thing I
know it has to do with this right so I
better get rid of my fractions and
subsequently students multiply through
now you can't do that you can't do that
because you don't know what this thing
is equal to it's a function you should
have factorized out which is exactly
what I've done over here
okay so please be careful with how
you're working with these polynomials if
you had something equals zero if you
knew it was equal to zero and you could
multiply through but the whole point was
to prove that it equals zero which is
what makes it a real
you're given that PFW is zero yep yep to
prove what to prove which part okay I'm
happy to look at it in a second okay
I'll look at it in a bit more detail
okay
now part two the people who survived
part one were okay with this but a lot
of people came out of the example and
said boy long exam long exam it's
because you didn't spend six lines on
this you spent 16 lines on this by
converting for some inscrutable reason
into modern form now okay saw your prey
for a second can anyone tell me why I'm
honestly interested in why you would
convert into Morag form here because I'm
just mystified I was looking at it again
also why do people do this
for someone who did can they tell me why
they went that way I carry okay I see
what you mean yeah all right
yeah I'll try this one
give it a go okay gotcha all right I'm
with you okay so I guess now we
recognize this oh my dog form what I
form the place you should go in what I
call it complex what you have with you
is one of them but you don't even have
to use what I feel for complex conjugate
root theorem the place I pretty much
only go there if I have to deal with
angles or if I have to do with democracy
room and I didn't have to do either FEM
in this case so I guess for you next
time that's a bit of a cue don't go
there could even just writing things in
my line form takes forever okay so not
only do you get more lines the lines
were very time-consuming this is the way
that was simplest okay no that's okay I
will point out the other issue was that
um people forgot this was an octave
equation so it had eight solutions right
so you can see when you go from Z to the
4 to Z squared you get a pair of
solutions right and then when you go
from Z squared to Z you get a pair of
solutions for each of the things in your
pair right and and the same thing
happens over here so there are eight
solutions in total and quite a few
students forgot that yep so if you got
here okay I'll have a look at it you
know happy to do them right something
for me
yeah this one know which one we're
looking hold on do you mean
whoopsie-daisy I'm just sorry do you
mean this one here yeah
that's supposed to be a - yeah fixed
okay yeah happy what right let's move on
okay in a quality person I don't I don't
I feel bad if you struggled with this
one okay but here's a lesson for you
right hopefully some of you did this
anyway again when it comes to time time
is precious
if you're known to call these a weak
point for you they come back don't sink
your time into this okay do it if you
can do it efficiently that's just a
general exam technique for a three-hour
exam you cannot afford to spend 10 to 12
minutes on a question worth what was it
worth yeah one and then - that was it
okay if you see it yeah yes right one
one equals two so if you see it go for
it and you can see it pulls out fairly
quickly but if you don't see it move on
right you're gonna have to fight tooth
and nail to get those two marks back
later on so this is the way I went about
it right you can see I think that the
best way to go is to start from a known
result and then shift around and add
equations or I should say inequalities
together to get x + y + Z all together
right so you can see if you've got
things about X Y & Z like up the top X
minus y or squared is greater than zero
that seems like an obvious place to go
because what question what part of the
question sort of clued you into that
there are two things now number one
number one there are squares okay just
square something please I think most
people recognize that but number two to
get to this x squared plus y squared 2
XY thing then you work you want this
negative here you see that so that when
it migrates over to the other side you
get X ray and plus y squared is greater
than 2 X 1 okay and then you can
progress them there
yet you'll get this you'll get to see
you can scrutinize oh I guess like I
said so this was the feedback given
right so if you're not sure shelve it
and come back okay there are easy marks
to be had elsewhere or quicker marks at
least okay let's have a look at this
ellipse so you got thrown a mark part
one you should have gotten on autopilot
okay
finding the equation of the tangent in
classic form not quite a contact not
something really challenging like that
this should have been easy to get okay
so two marks there right now the hard
part started okay now some people said I
didn't know the area of an ellipse keep
in mind keep in mind you get given this
result about the ratio okay you get
given this two to the two ratio 2pi tan
theta okay so that the area of ellipse
is implied if you can get the area of
the triangle right now that's slightly
shady but it works it's fine and also
when you think about the area of a
circle by r-squared it is just the
special version where a and B are both
the same and they're both the radius
okay so people really struggle it to
progresses I just want you to UM look at
this with me for a moment when you have
a look I know I have fancy colors that
help you see the diagram okay but even I
once I had this I have to put together
something like this for myself because
I'm like I can't see what's going on
even on a beautiful diagram like that
and you've just drawn it for the first
time I had to draw for myself this guy
over here subsidiary diagrams bonus
diagrams a take out they pull out the
relevant part in the secretary question
also very valuable they help you get
okay these are the coordinates so these
are the lengths the the base the
perpendicular height and that's where
you get your area at all once you see
this you see what I mean by the area of
the ellipse is implied in here right
it's like all the pie a B is what gets
this factored out okay so if you were
careful with this part that's what got
you the area that was the hardest part I
think seeing the triangle and working up
what's a smart way to work out its area
okay you've got no angles in there uh if
you go towards
half a b-side see you're just interested
like you need angles for that so you
really had to go with base and
perpendicular height
you just had to choose one appropriately
how did I know to choose OS as the
perpendicular height sorry at the base
how did I know that would give me
clearly the quickest way yeah it's
pretty cool look at the other two
they're like offer these we do random
angles I don't want to find that
distance it's gonna be it's gonna be
terrible so choose that carefully and
there's a oh well therefore the
perpendicular height must be an
x-coordinate and that's how it fell out
okay and then you simply had to
progression there and it was a it was a
simple ratio to a value right our one
last question there's an absolute value
in that ten theta right why is that
there right because this diagram is just
one version of this pick and go anywhere
it likes right so some people ignored
like they tried to progress through and
ignore the absolute value but P could be
like over here could hang out there
right in which case my x coordinates or
my Y coordinates if I'm down here they
can be negative so that's what the
absolute value fixes for me I just want
the magnitudes of those lines that was a
challenging question the geometry of it